[DRUMS PLAYING]
It's really cool that MIT flew
out an entire 25 piece big band
all the way to Puerto Rico.
[DRUMS PLAYING]
When I was a freshman
first joining the ensemble,
it's not something I
would ever have imagined--
going on tour with Miguel
Zenón in Puerto Rico.
[SAXOPHONE PLAYING]
[DRUMS PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
Now that you saw the
demonstration that they had,
I think [SPEAKING SPANISH].
He wanted to see if
there were any volunteers
to come up and dance.
[AUDIENCE CHEERING]
[DRUMS PLAYING]
My parents are Nigerian.
They listen to a lot of
traditional African music.
And from a rhythmic
standpoint, it's very similar.
[JAZZ MUSIC PLAYING]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
A big part of MIT's
vision is to take
all the skills and the
knowledge that the students have
acquired, and to go forth
and spread it, and try
to use those skills for good.
And I really think that
this trip is very much
an extension of MIT's
dedication to trying
to change the world positively.
[JAZZ MUSIC PLAYING]
My name is Peter.
I'm from Massachusetts.
I go to the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology.
Today, we've been
talking to middle school
and high schoolers.
And my goal throughout
this process
is to inspire them to
begin thinking about ways
that they can directly
impact their own communities.
This area was very affected by
Hurricane Maria with flooding
of a few feet of water that
stayed inside the houses
for 16 days.
And they had no power
for around four months.
[JAZZ MUSIC PLAYING]
I've seen a remarkable
example of the resiliency
of the human spirit,
and people's ability
to recover in any situation.
Close to 300 schools
have been closed
as a result of the storm.
And the people are now moving
to reclaim these properties,
and convert them into something
else like a multicultural arts
center that will give students
and artists in the community
a place to rehearse, or a place
to perform, or just a place
to gather and share their art.
In the school we just visited,
there is no electricity.
And so right now, they're
trying to figure out
how can they take solar
panels and batteries
and supply the power required
to run that facility.
I'm extremely grateful for
you guys being here this week.
I'm sure you know how
much this means to me,
and how long we've worked
to make this happen.
This has exceeded
all my expectations.
And hopefully, you got
something really good from it.
I can assure you
that everyone you
met this week and everyone
who heard you play and heard
you speak got a lot from
it and is going to make
a difference in their life.
So thank you so
much for being here.
I really, really appreciate it.
[PIANO MUSIC PLAYING]
I get so much joy out of seeing
this kind of thing happen.
It's the greatest thing
that could happen.
And it's the greatest reward
that music could give me.
[FESTIVE MUSIC PLAYING]
[AUDIENCE CHEERING]
[AUDIENCE SHOUTING IN SPANISH]